jetzt sprechen wir darüber mit den
sicherheitsexperten und
politikwissenschaftler markus kaim von
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik
guten morgen morgen also finnland und
schweden wollen in die nato erhoffen
sich dadurch natürlich für sich selbst
ein stück weit auch mehr sicherheit
durch diese bündniszugehörigkeit aber
andersrum gefragt was hat die nato
eigentlich von dem beitritt durch diese
beiden länder es ist ein großer mehrwert
sind greift der demokratien im gegensatz
zu vielen ländern die vor 30 jahren
mitglied geworden sind wo man nicht
genau wusste in welche richtung die sich
entwickeln das ist bei finnland und
schweden völlig unzweifelhaft und sie
sind verteidigung und sicherheit würden
sich gut aufgestellt man kann das auch
in finnland erklären man hat die
wehrpflicht nicht abgeschafft findet
investiert 2 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts und
verteidigungsausgaben man hat eine
vergleichsweise kleine armee mit 30.000
man hierbei aufwachsen kann bis zu
900.000 und die gesamte gesellschaft ist
für den verteidigungsfall ausgerichtet
und das ist der große mehrwert für die
nato russlands präsident putin hat sich
dazu ja auch schon geäußert und gesagt
naja nato-beitritt durch finnland und
schweden das sei per se jetzt erst mal
gar nicht so die große bedrohung und das
große problem es sei denn man würde
direkt an der grenze eben aufrüsten und
dann wäre es eine unmittelbare reaktion
geben welche art von reaktion ist
denkbar das wissen wir nicht aber der
eindruck ist genau richtig die reaktion
moskaus war vergleichsweise verhalten
wir sind in den letzten wochen ja sehr
robuste drohungen gewohnt und zwar so zu
formulieren und das war doch sehr
zurückgenommen man nannte das ein
problem gefahr der instabilität der
stabilisierung aber direkte drohung den
sinn von benny dieses tutogen ist das
war nicht der fall und wenn ich das
richtig verfolgt habe in den letzten
tagen sind ja beide länder sehr
vorsichtig trotz des nato beitritts ihr
verhältnis zu russland nicht zu sehr zu
belasten gerade später gestern
angekündigt keine neuen nato stützpunkte
auf reede dem territorium und keine
nuklearwaffen sollen dort rationiert
werden das deute so ein bisschen anders
man auf russland auch rücksicht nimmt
das ganze kann jetzt ja
mehr oder weniger im schnellverfahren
über die bühne gehen tatsächlich der
türkische präsident präsident erdogan
wer diese nato-beitritt allerdings nicht
billigen daraus ergibt sich die frage
kann es eigentlich verhindern und was
erhofft sich erdogan möglicherweise
jetzt auch in den verhandlung also
technik kann das verändern weil alle 30
nato mitglieder müssten zustimmen die
drucke und türkei als eines von
dementsprechend ist halt zustände
erforderlich ich bin ein bisschen
zurückhaltend zu glauben dass er den
verlängerten arm ostern ist das damit
einfluss nimmt mir scheint es eher zu
sein dass die türkei einen preis haben
will die türkei war in den letzten
jahren sehr sperriger partner innerhalb
des bündnisses unterliegt amerikaner in
rüstungs restriktion bekommt bestimmte
waffensysteme nicht geliefert sie sind
an einem system epss 36 flugzeug
interessiert und ich kann mir durchaus
vorstellen dass die usa als
führungsmacht der nato da
entgegenkommend wirken werden dann
blicken wir noch auf die aktuelle lage
in der ukraine
wie ordnen sie das kriegsgeschehen
momentan ein der regierungssprecher
sprach gestern schon von einer wende hin
zum stellungskrieg würden sie das auch
so die absolut absolut zutreffend wir
sehen dass letztlich erinnert dass man
sollte zurückhaltend seien jetzt auch
analogien aber an den ersten weltkrieg
den stellungskrieg zwischen deutschland
und frankreich die front bewegt die fünf
kilometer in die eine richtung dann fünf
kilometer in die andere richtung
substanzielle gewinne sind nicht
erkennbar weder für die eine noch für
die andere seite und das einzig positive
an der situation ist dass solange sich
die akteure aneinander ermüden wenn ich
das so sagen darf dann öffnet sich die
tür für diplomatie weil dann macht ihr
krieg keinen sinn mehr jetzt ist ja die
frage wie man im westen mit dieser
situation umgeht und wir wissen in
brüssel streiten die eu mitgliedstaaten
momentan vor allen dingen mit ungarn zum
thema öl embargo wie sehr schmerzen die
diese
diese sanktionen putin also überhaupt im
moment sieht schmerz mehr sehen als an
der ökonomischen kennzahlen die
unabweisbar sind aber ich glaube der
entscheidende punkt ist beeinflussen sie
das kosten nutzen kalkül des russischen
präsidenten und da müssen wir stand 17
mai also nach acht wochen gut acht
wochen krieg konstatieren sie tun es
nicht er sieht sich eben noch nicht
genötigt den krieg zu beenden
das soll man das heißen mag oder
zumindest anderem warfen stellt dann
zuzustimmen dementsprechend sind die
überlangen sanktionen aber das haben die
wunde hat die bundesregierung von anfang
an ja auch gesagt ihr auf lange frist
angelegt markus kaim war das
sicherheitsexperte und
politikwissenschaftler von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik vielen dank für
das gespräch
ihre anordnung dankeschön